I'm going crazy self isolating and it's
only been ten days but this guy he was
isolated for 520 days Oh Masha she can
tell us how to stay sane and deal with
cabin fever during the corona crisis I
mean you're the perfect person to talk
to basically about this topic
thank you it's true that my story
becomes a bit more relevant right now so
many of us including me here in Berlin
are in self-isolation due to the corona
pandemic or even in quarantine how's
everybody's self-isolation going I mean
quarantine for 14 I guess it doesn't
seem that bad - most people yet but
being stuck inside for a long period of
time can have serious consequences
people feel upset homeless crass it's a
situation almost all of us on YouTube
except for this guy he spent five
hundred and twenty days on lockdown with
five of the guys inside a mock
spacecraft in Moscow so I asked him and
the professor of psychiatry who studied
South patients in isolation how to deal
with being isolated specifically how to
deal with cabin fever the first thing is
to to realize why you want to do that
what is your motivation and and I think
that applies still today with our
confinement for me at that time it was
to to bring my little break on the way
leading to the expression of MRSA today
our purpose to be confined is to protect
our famiiy your friends I really hate
that we can't properly go outside but
maybe it does help when I remind myself
more often
why are we actually doing this that's
missing the dirties alibi - a moment is
nua absent our stock falls over
[Music]
have things to do even watching a movie
reading a book but plan things during
the hold s that at the end of the day we
say okay I did all that and I know I
still have that to do so tomorrow I
would do it this way you live in the
present you don't look at the big
picture and being busy you don't you
don't sit down and start to have dark
thoughts cabin fever isn't a
psychological disorder to be honest I
didn't take it that seriously but it
turns out that its effects can have
grave psychological consequences
Remis tyra researched the effects of
isolation on patients who are
quarantined during the SARS epidemic and
what we found was that there was a high
percentage of people who had for PTSD
and depression from having been in
quarantine during the SARS episode they
feel there's a lack of control they
often have difficulty sleeping so you
have to keep yourself busy it's a great
time to learn new skills start new
hobbies take a course start an
initiative that you've always wanted to
do that you didn't have time to do keep
in touch with your close ones that's
really important keep in touch with
family and friends by using technology
they will provide you a tremendous
amount of support
now there's more of a sense of community
there's so many people in isolation that
people don't feel they're the only ones
even if you're alone in it you're not
really because there's so many other
people were sort of look that's right we
had eight hours of work eight hours of
free time and eight hours of sleep we
all created our own little routines that
that were working and I think it was
important to have those routines to to
structure each thing so you have
something that you know you're gonna do
every single day and routine helps in
calming one's fears and anxieties I get
up every morning at the same time I put
on my makeup or there no one will see me
and make myself the same breakfast every
day you know I do all of this just to
pretend that everything's normal
ah those routines after some time would
become monotonous so we we had to kind
of break this monotony from time to time
by by making a day different from others
for example remember that for Halloween
we decided to dress up and do the whole
day dressed up and in the evening we
would watch some horror movies to get
ever just because equals Halloween and
to make it different breaking this
monetary gives some energy to continue
on for the mission but for the
confinement too
[Music]
okay and when entering the modules I to
myself okay this is my universe now
everything I cannot do right now I will
just do it in a year and a half and that
can still be the case today for the
people confined wait for that the
excitement of doing it at that time when
it will be possible again being confined
for such a long period of time they are
seeing that we do not have and we don't
really realize that we are missing them
or that they are not there but when you
are back to a normal life after and did
you see them or get them again it's so
great a few weeks ago it was just so
normal to go out hang out with friends
whenever I wanted I just took it for
granted like everybody else I'm sure I'm
going to appreciate the small things in
life more once we all get out of this
matter which questions would you like to
know about your life in the corona
crisis please just let us know and leave
a comment